wilco so hier und ich würde gern von dir
simon wissen
ob man wenn gamern so lange existiert
vielleicht das wäre
frühestens fünf jahren bei euch eine art
studentenjob bekommen könnte alle unsere
jobs sind studentenjobs wenn
studentische job bedeutet dass man kaum
geld kriegt und viel arbeitet und man
immer zu hören kriegt ja aber das kannst
du in deinen lebenslauf schreiben das
ist für mich die definition eines jobs
und aufnahme genug wenn du die leute
fragt sie bei uns arbeiten die würden
sagen ja ich will lieber mehr geld
kriegen und dafür halt keine ahnung eine
sicherheit haben oder so ich glaube
nicht dass es in fünf jahren gehen wir
noch gibt
ja kaum etwas
was existiert zehn jahre was kann
überhaupt zehn jahre lang interessant
sein
welches konzept trägt sich zehn jahre
ich glaube nicht dass es irgendetwas
gibt was da so direkt mir jetzt einfällt
was er auch passen würde deswegen werden
wir leider in fünf jahren nicht mehr da
sein aber das ist ja das positive wir
müssen alle geld verdienen wir haben
nichts anderes gelernt deswegen wird es
verschiedene games änderung oder
verschiedene sachen zum thema geben wer
weiß vielleicht interessierst du dich in
fünf jahren für pferde und dann kannst
du wahrscheinlich gibt es ein pferde
sender gibt sich ein pferde sender in
fünf jahren dann kannst du dahin wichtig
ist nur dass du halt dich nicht
entmutigen lässt und auch nicht alles
was du machen willst jetzt projiziert
darauf ob es ob wir gerade im platz
haben für praktikanten das ist alles
sehr viel zu sehr vom vom zufall
abhängig
überleg dir dass du machen willst
forscher im netz nachfrage leute die
sowas machen wie mich jetzt oder so was
man dafür können lernen denken muss und
versucht sich dann einfach zu bewerben
in fünf jahren also nicht nur bei uns
sondern bei allem was dich interessiert
bei allen sendern bei allen sendungen
bei allen teams weil ich glaube man
sollte sich nicht auf eine sache jetzt
versteifen sondern man sollte wirklich
auch gucken dass man sich selbst
weiterentwickelt was bringt es wenn du
jetzt wie ich glaube die hat dann nicht
wer ist der typ bei dsds der wie michael
jackson ist jedes jahr wieder kommt wenn
die iris menn der ist genau das also da
zwar jetzt endlich den recall geschafft
aber er hat acht jahre seines lebens
oder 10 hat er halt irgendwie auch
verschwendet immer darauf zu hoffen dass
ist gehabt und das sollte man vielleicht
nicht machen also in der zeit kann man
besseres machen und wahrscheinlich
arbeiten wir in fünf jahren für dich